to present the award for film editing  the lady who made 10 the number to shoot  for Bo Derek and here to protect her for  from the forces of evil is Christopher  Reeve  the nominees for outstanding achievement  in film editing are Alan Heim for all  that jazz Walter Murch  Gerald B Greenberg and Lisa Freeman for  Apocalypse Now  Robert Alva for the Black Stallion  and Jerry greenberg for Kramer vs Kramer  Robert L wolf and Timothy O'Meara for  the rose right the winner is  Alan Heim for all that jazz  I'd like to thank Bob Fosse and just  cetera to know for making a film so  beautiful and so complex that I'm here  tonight I'd like to thank all the people  who worked so hard with me in the  editing room particularly David ray  Wendy Pfeiffer  Emily Payne and John Cameron and my wife  and my daughter and all my family and  friends for putting up with a year of  obsessive behavior thank you